listen we know that you love threading
and we know that for 99% of your
threading needs async task is the right
solution but for the other work you
might need a different kind of threading
primitive my name is Colt McAnlis and
for the types of work that might not
deal with UI updates handler threads are
a nifty solution see when it comes to
threading work most devs have a
round-trip model now you've got some
work you want it tossed from the UI
thread to some other thread and then
when the work needs to come back to the
UI thread you've got to update some
visual thingamajigger or whatever for
these types of situations async task is
obviously the easiest solution for you I
mean it wraps up all the overhead of
pushing work from the UI thread to a
worker thread and then getting the
results back to the UI thread
but async task isn't the right threading
primitive for every situation consider
the challenge of getting preview frames
from your camera these previews are
given back to you via the on preview
frame callback which is a vocht on the
same thread that the camera dot open
function was called on so if this
callback were invoked on the UI thread
then the task of dealing with those huge
pixel arrays would be interfering with
rendering and event processing work and
same thing goes for async tasks remember
that by default these execute serially
on another thread which means that
dealing with an 8 megapixels block of
data might stall other async task
packets that the UI thread is waiting on
so really what you want is a non UI non
async task thread they can receive these
callbacks and potentially spend a long
time processing that work and this is
exactly what handler thread is for see a
handler thread is effectively a
long-running thread that grabs work from
a queue and operates on it it's a
combination of a few other Android
primitives namely a looper which keeps
the thread alive and holds a message
queue and a handler object which manages
how work is inserted into that message
queue anyhow getting back to our camera
example once you've created a handler
thread you can delegate the camera dot
open command to it and know that the on
preview frame callback will land on the
handler thread rather than the UI or
async task threads so if you're going to
be doing a long-running block of work on
those pixels this is ideal for you and
to be clear getting the results of that
work back to you
my thread is pretty straightforward just
pass it along with V run on UI thread
command so handler threads are obviously
helpful for other Android AP eyes that
follow a similar pattern but they can
also be useful for longer running non UI
work like a compressing a batch of user
metrics before uploading it to your
server if you've got other UI specific
tasks happening on async tasks then you
might not want this longer running
operation to stall that work so handler
threads are a good place for it oh by
the way when you create a hammer thread
don't forget to set its thread priority
based on the type of work it's doing I
mean remember CPUs can only handle a
small number of threads in parallel so
setting the priority helps the system
know the right ways to schedule this
work when the other threads are fighting
for attention and that's the whole thing
when it comes to performance coding you
have to understand enough about the
primitives to know how they help you and
how they might hurt you and if it's not
working move on to a better pattern
which is why you should check out the
rest of the Android performance patterns
videos and don't forget to ask the hard
threading questions on the Google+
community as well so keep calm profile
your code and always remember perf
matters